♪ (music) ♪
Welcome back.
- I'm Paige Bailey, and this is...
- Laurence Moroney,
and we are here to answer
all of your Ask TensorFlow questions
at the TensorFlow Dev Summit.
So, if you have any questions,
please submit them to social media
with the hashtag #AskTensorFlow.
And we'll answer
as many of them as we can,
but any that we can't get to today
we'll try to reach out to you later
- to answer them.
- Absolutely.
So let's get started
with the first question.
- Okay, so shall I try this one?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So this one, I think, came on Twitter,
from @yuehgoh, and it said:
"Once I installed tensorflow-gpu,
import did not work for me.
I have been trying to use it,"
but has been unable to do so.
"It fails to load
native tensorflow runtime."
I remember seeing this one.
Actually, it was on YouTube,
and it was in response to one of my videos
about pip-installed
TensorFlow GPU in Colab,
because once upon a time in Colab,
you had to pip install TensorFlow GPU
to be able to use it,
and now if you try to do that,
you end up having some issues.
The reason for that is actually
really good, and it's good news,
and it's because you don't need
to do it anymore.
Excellent!
So, actually, if we switch to Colab
for a second on my laptop,
I can show you.
This was the notebook
that I was showing earlier on.
And all you have to do,
if you want to use GPU in Colab,
is just change your runtime type,
pick GPU as the hardware accelerator,
and now you don't need
to pip install TensorFlow GPU;
it actually does it for you
under the hood, behind the scenes.
It's really, really cool,
and that's why earlier
I was able to train this so quickly,
because I was actually using the GPU.
And, as you can see,
there's no pip install GPU on here.
(Paige) Excellent.
Whenever we were initially testing
TensorFlow 2.0,
we had a kind of similar issue,
as well, with the GPU install,
in that you needed specific CUDA drivers.
But now, CUDA 10
is supported in Colab, as well.
So Colab is a great experience
if you're using a GPU
or if you're using
any other accelerated hardware.
(Laurence) Yeah, and a pro tip
going forward, as well,
if you want to do GPU stuff,
because this was something
that I ran into a number of times
when trying to use the GPU,
was that you always
have to carefully take a look
at the version of CUDA
and cuDNN that you're using.
Because I made the mistake
that I just went to the vendor's website,
I downloaded the latest versions,
I installed them,
and then I saw TensorFlow
was actually supporting
a slightly earlier version.
So if you do get an error
when you're trying to use GPU,
just take a look at the version
of the driver
that it's looking to support,
and then, from the vendor's website,
download that specific version.
- (Paige) Yeah, driver issues...
- Driver issues.
(Paige) They're always a treat, right?
Exactly!
It's one of the things
that makes our job interesting.
Absolutely.
Alright, so shall we take a look
at the next one?
Yeah, let's go-- Oh! @adkumar!
So @adkumar had at least eight
excellent questions on Twitter.
Maybe he wins the volume award.
He absolutely does!
And we'll get to all of them,
not in this sort of
Ask TensorFlow segment,
but let's focus on just one for today
and then answer the rest offline.
Yeah, and I think a lot of them
were really about file formats
and how do I use different file formats,
so shall we drill into that?
Absolutely. So the question is:
"Which is the preferred format
for saving the model going forward,"
saved_model or something else?
And, if we look at the laptop,
we can take a gander
at one of the slides
from the keynote this morning,
really showing that Keras
is a first-class citizen
in TensorFlow 2.0
and SavedModel is at the heart
of every deployment.
So here you can see SavedModel
being used for TensorFlow Serving,
for TensorFlow Lite, for TensorFlow.js,
and lots of other language bindings,
so really, we're pushing
for the SavedModel.
(Laurence) And if you focus
on SavedModel you can't go wrong.
(Paige) Yes, absolutely.
It's a lot easier to use
than some of the other deployment options
that we'd seen before.
Yeah, so I think the guidance
would be in the recommendation,
not just for AD, but for everybody else.
And, when you're thinking
about saving out your models,
take a look at SavedModel,
consider using SavedModel,
and, as a result, it's not only
is the advantage of the file format,
but just how it's supported
across all of these things.
And an excellent point of TensorFlow 2.0--
I'm just going to keep selling it--
is that we have a number
of code samples and tutorials
available today
about how you can deploy
your models with SavedModel.
Yeah, and I've personally found,
from playing with some
of the TensorFlow Lite stuff in 2.0,
saving as a SavedModel
and then going through the conversion
to the TF Lite process,
it was a lot easier for me
than in previous iterations
where I had to use TocoConverter
and all that kind of stuff.
So it's really being refined.
We're really iterating on that.
- And I think it looks really cool!
- Excellent!
So thanks for all of those questions, AD.
There's some great stuff in there.
We'll try to answer
some of the rest of them,
but understood that
most of them are focused
around the file format
and hopefully SavedModel will help you.
- Alright.
- Perfect, so let's go to the next one.
So this next one comes from Elie Gakuba,
asking, "Is it possible
to run tensorboard on colabs?"
- And I know this made Paige really happy!
- Ah, yes!!
Oh, dude! You are going
to be so delighted!
Because before TensorBoard
was running on Colabs,
we were talking about it:
"We really want it on Colabs!"
It was so painful.
And if you wanted to get it working
in a Colab notebook or in Jupyter,
you ended up using a tool like Ngrok,
and that was kind of not approved
by our bosses, or in general.
But yes, the good news is that
you can run TensorBoard in Colabs.
(Laurence) And when it was
first announced internally in Google,
before it was publically announced,
we all got this email from Paige,
and it was full of all these
smiley emojis and hearts.
(Paige laughs)
So, Elie, thank you for the question,
because I think you've made Paige's day.
(Paige) Excellent!
And so you can see here in the Colab,
I'm running through
and downloading some files
in the hope that we could
play with it a little bit,
but here you can see it actually working.
You should be able to do
different operations like smoothing,
changing some of the values,
and then also using
the embedding visualizer
directly from your Colab notebook
in order to understand your accuracies
and to be able to do
model performance debugging.
Another nice thing that the team
has been working very, very hard on
is that you don't have to specify ports.
So you don't have to remember
if you wanted to have
multiple TensorBoard instances running,
that you were using, what is it,
6006, or whatever, for another.
It just automatically selects one
that would be a good candidate
and creates it for you.
So the team is phenomenal.
If you have any interest whatsoever
in TensorBoard at all,
I suggest stalking their PRs, like I do,
because that's how I found out
that TensorBoard got added
to Jupyter notebooks and also to Colab.
But, yeah, so excited.
And we'll have this link
in the documentation for the video,
as well, the little notes underneath,
for you to go and play with.
And I do have to say, it's so great
to have a PR stalker in our group.
(laughter)
I get push notifications
to my phone-- It's a problem.
But yeah, they've been doing
such great work.
(Laurence) So the question is yes,
TensorBoard is working in Colab.
- And also Project Jupyter notebooks!
- Nice.
Use it wherever!
TensorBoard everywhere!
TensorBoard everywhere;
we all love TensorBoard.
I haven't really played with it that much,
but do a lot of the plugins also work?
So TensorBoard really is a collection
of these different visualizations,
so you can see scalers,
like your accuracy;
you can see histograms;
you can see embedding visualizers,
which allows you to do clustering,
like that great MNIST example
from the Dev Summit a couple years ago.
- With all that stuff.
- Moving it around.
- I play with that all day.
- It's beautiful.
And then also Beholder,
which was created by a community member.
The plugins...
It's so funny you mention it.
A couple of our GSOC,
our Google Summer of Code projects
this summer are focused on getting
additional visualization plugins
added to TensorBoard.
(Laurence) Cool! Nice!
So in addition to the What-If Tool,
in addition to Beholder,
you could make
your own TensorBoard plugin.
While I could geek out about this all day,
I think we should move on
to some other questions
that some folks have had.
Can't we kick out about this all day?
Can we extend the stream
for three or four hours?
So the next question that came in,
from Amirhosein Herandy,
"How would you use
feature_columns with Keras?"
I know you know
the answer to this question.
But I know that it's
a particular passion of yours
that you're working
with Estimators in Keras.
So, for the folks who are watching,
feature columns
are really part of Estimators.
They're a way of really getting your data
efficiently into Estimators.
And with people saying,
"Hey, it's all there in Estimators.
What about Keras?"
You've been working on
some great stuff around that, right?
I have, but I know
that your YouTube channel
has a series from Karmel,
who spoke earlier today.
Yeah, so Karmel
is our engineering director
for high-level APIs,
and she has this great series
around high-level APIs for TensorFlow,
really, really teaching you
how to use the high-level APIs.
And Karmel is working actively,
and her team are working actively,
for parity of things
like feature columns in TensorFlow 2.0.
I'm not sure if it's fully
there yet in the Alpha.
I haven't checked into it yet.
But, yeah, it's on the way,
if it's not there already.
So you should be able
to use them in Keras.
(Paige) Yes, and we're also
in the process of building out--
If you wanted to migrate your models
from using Estimators
to being more
of a TensorFlow 2.0 format
with Keras,
I am currently in the process
of building a migration guide.
So if you have any interest around that,
please feel free to reach out.
And we're excited
to get that released pretty soon.
I'm really excited
to see that, personally,
because the very first stuff
I did in TensorFlow
was with Estimators,
before I learned Keras,
and I really want to go back
and start changing them to use Keras
without rewriting them.
Absolutely.
Keras is just friendlier
to work with, my feel.
Yeah, so they're both great.
Estimators really gives you the power.
Keras, great for beginners.
So hopefully we'll get
the best of both worlds.
Shall we take a look at the next question?
Yes!
Jeff Thomas asks,
"looking for some simple data sets
for testing and comparing
different training methods."
Aha! Different!
"Looking for new data sets."
MNIST is great. Fashion-MNIST is great.
But, after a while,
people want something
new and fresh, right?
Yes.
What do you think we can say to Jeff?
We could tell them
about TensorFlow Datasets!
And there's a great blog post
right here about it.
Yes, it is.
And TensorFlow Datasets
is really about creating
those data-ingestion pipelines
for you to be able to easily use
a variety of datasets
with all of your deep learning
and machine learning models
with just a few lines of code.
So, if you're familiar with Scikit-learn
and all of its nifty
data-ingestion practices,
this feels very similar.
It's very easy to do training
and testing splits
and verification [splits],
and we have a lot of datasets
readily available right now
for you to go and explore.
Another thing that I would
especially like to call out
is a member of our community--
So anybody can make your data famous.
If you have a dataset that you're using
in your research lab,
if you have a bright and shiny CSV
that you think would be a cool add
to the structured section--
I've never heard a CSV
called bright and shiny before.
Well, you know... Everybody uses them.
One of our community members,
Andrew Kondrich,
who's an undergrad researcher at Stanford,
he added this CheXpert Dataset
from his lab--
200,000 chest radiograms,
from the Stanford ML group.
And he was able to do it
in less than a day.
It really is just as simple as--
take the template format
for images or for audio
or whatever you're using,
add some additional metadata
for the dataset,
change, potentially, the types
for some of the features
that you're using with it,
- and, voila! there you go.
- You're off to the races!
Absolutely, and you can
make your data famous!
And one of the really
important things about it,
particularly if you're getting started
or if you're learning,
is that if you take a look
at a lot of the samples
pre-TensorFlow Datasets.
There tends to be lots and lots of code
about download your data,
unzip it here, label it like this,
put these files in these folders,
or take your CSV and make these features,
but when it's in TFDS,
it's like one or two lines of code,
and the data will just get sorted
into training and test sets for you,
that type of thing.
So I think for learners, in particular,
I found it really, really exciting
because I didn't have
to go through 100 lines of code
before I got to the [neural] network.
And also data science-y people.
So much of creating and training a model
is understanding the shape and the format
and the statistical distributions,
and this is really helpful.
(Laurence) Yeah. So thanks very much.
♪ (music) ♪